oh my god Oh all that stuff wild boar
well I hope it doesn't taste boring okay
a lot of pepper I don't like that it
looks like mummified fingers if it
totally looks like a finger
there's tation what pig that's funny did
you say that because I think this tastes
more like that's good I like this one
it's like thick and juicy it's like the
mentoring my mouth right now ostrich
right away it smells like dog treats
well this is great off link to me I
would stop it like a shady 7-eleven and
pick up some ostrich any day you know
this tastes like hmm a leather belt it's
a good shoe though it's something you
could continue it's like gum it's meat
gum oh I don't like it I like it
all right alligator this one looks like
you need to put chapstick on it cuz it's
so dry this is a group from guardians of
the galaxy that looks inviting let's try
it oh uh what stuff and dry maybe this
is alligator bones maybe you shouldn't
make jerky out of alligator it spent so
much time thinking if you could you
didn't stop and think upon my mouth and
be like oh that's alligator that's what
she said I just I don't know
how would she say that don't pack our
alpacas are my favourite this does smell
better
this smells more like beefy look at this
face why would you make a pieces this
one looks a little bit like you really
does look like you oh it's not tough
it tastes like when we had order at
Applebee's once you get down to the core
of it it's good but you got to get
through that mean exterior it's like
Shrek it's a little more peppery too mmm
there's a little bit of a zing to it no
it's like the I'll pack indistinct you
too Betty yak huh yeah yak it smells
like someone who doesn't like wash their
hands but after going on the bathroom
this looks like it's like scorpion meat
uh-huh Carla now there's trouble River
City mmm
I think this one's the best one I kind
of like this one good mouthfeel
mouthfeel people throw that word around
feel as far as like Tibetan yaks go this
is probably the the best thing that
could come from it I think I've TMJ now
TMJ too much Turkey hahahaha so that is
the TMJ dude too much Turkey